kids are in Brooklyn all the cool kids
are there we're very excited about our
next guest actor Aisha Tyler is known
for a roles in her hit TV shows like
friends Archer and of course Criminal
Minds that's why she's here today
Criminal Minds aired for 15 seasons in
2021 it became the most watched show
across all of streaming and now good
news for you the show is back with a
Revival called Criminal Minds Evolution
and God it's so intense it follows an
FBI unit tasked with investigating a
network of serial killers not just one
serial killer a network Tyler returns as
her character Dr Tara Lou she's a
forensic psychologist in this clip from
tomorrow's new episode she talks to
technical analyst Penelope Garcia who's
a lot of fun about a missing dog that
might help them catch a killer here you
go
okay so it turns out this kind of
tracking device is used to track pets in
our case a dog a moose okay who did
moose belong to Tawny Smith from
Chattanooga Tennessee she's been posting
about most being missing since
Thanksgiving you're gonna have to be the
bearer of some terrible news hold on a
second
so curious took the dog and left Tony
alive yeah I was surprised too the
sicarious in my mind does not leave
people or pets breathing that just gives
you a sense of his discipline I mean he
needed the dog and not her
he's very disciplined I'll just say that
to you Criminal Minds Evolution streams
on Paramount plus which like CBS is part
of Paramount Global Aisha we're so glad
to tell you is here with us in studio hi
Tyler
we've all been marveling about your
resume all morning actor producer
director comedian talk show host sounds
like you're showing off or very
ambitious or just crippled with
workaholic it's probably the most likely
but I've heard you say yeah I'm
ambitious and I make no apologies for
that no and I mean I think women
specifically are made to feel bad about
being ambitious and made to feel bad
about saying that you know I really want
to push myself to do the best that I can
do I really want to challenge myself but
I feel like I give myself permission to
be ambitious I'm driven and I think that
women should do that as well you know
you can't do anything great without
aspiring to Greatness that's right and
also in this series you direct several
episodes too yes so they like sitting in
the director the one that's that's
airing this week as I directed it I like
sitting in the director's chair I love
it um because well for me you know lots
of different directors are different but
to me I feel like directing is being a
good coach and helping other people do
their best work it's not about being a
dictator or handing down edicts it's
about saying please feel free and safe
to do your best here feel free to take
risks I'm here to support you and high
tide raises all boats so if everybody's
having a good time and they're doing the
best work then the show is going to be
great and some of these new episodes
they dive into the agents lives outside
of the FBI and your character
specifically it's revealed that is in a
relationship with a woman yes you said
that you were excited about this twist
in the role I was they pitch it to me
before we started the show and um
unfortunately I'm straight but um
sorry I'm doing my best but um
but I have a lot like a lot of very
close friends of mine my sister are gay
and I really wanted to honor that
storyline and bring a relationship that
felt loving and real and dynamic and
authentic not perfect because
relationships you know human beings are
human beings because they have issues
just like like everybody else you know
and I think you want to bring these
nuanced portrayals of gay characters to
the screen be authentic as authentic as
we can possibly be but I love how you
said you wanted to honor that yeah
this is a tight-knit cast you guys have
known each other uh when the last season
wrapped in 2020 apparently you guys
stayed on in touch on a text chain we
have a three of a text thread that um is
alternately about you know dog videos
and where we're all going to eat we do a
lot of congratulating each other on our
projects anyone ever silence
notifications I mean who who abuses the
change
um I mean probably the most talkative
two people are me and Kirsten I think
we're the chattiest
um also everybody's made memories of
themselves so sometimes it's just like
an emoji battle
is just a silver fox that he is
um but you know we were really lucky we
ended the show on season 15 very very
tight-knit and the joy of like getting
the band back together has just been
unbelievable and also hosting Whose Line
Is It Anyway yeah it's a classic show
too yeah we're shooting our final season
this month which I'm really excited
about again another band another really
fun getting back together and just the
best improvisers in the business is so
funny these guys and um they're often
telling me like Aisha can you actually
laugh a little more quietly
I mean I'm like I feel like somebody's
mouth I'm like whoa he's so funny that
was good exactly I love it does the talk
seem like a total lifetime ago to you it
does it seems like a different person it
does I'm so good on that oh thank you it
was a great time in my life I grew and I
learned a lot and I left because I
wanted to be a director and it was a
dream and you've got to make space for
your dreams and I left there and I've
directed 10 episodes of television and a
movie and about to get ready to direct
another film so it was the right move
for me
so you're missing the talk I'm
yeah
you got to make space for your dreams
that's right I like that Golden Era for
revivals you could revive that role as
well can we just ask what your next
stream is what is my next dream oh my
gosh well I'm getting ready to direct a
big action movie which is very ruling
for me and um and also my next stream is
to try to get eight hours of sleep on a
regular basis all these articles are
coming out telling me that you know I
need to get more sleep need any extras
for that action movie I'll be in touch
there you go Tony and I have been
working out exhibit a and exhibit B they
can rip his sleeves off I've seen him do
that it's good to see you Aisha
congratulations
she's a badass kick a butt that's right
Criminal Minds evolution is streaming
right now on Paramount plus with new
episodes out on Thursday Did I mention
she's directing the two we'll be right
back so you've also done voiceover for
video